four three two one
[Music]
welcome back to another episode
jake knows two chords and he might know
three
[Music]
or maybe it's just an augmented version
of the same
thing nice
all right guys sitcom intro man it i
know
we can sing and play at the same time i
it's taken me years
and i'm not good at it but i can do it
i will say i can do it
[Music]
judging by how you're the rock i mean i
i say you can do it
well thanks for pointing that out thanks
for pointing that out
because i um i don't know if you guys
watch
uh corridor crew hopefully you do but
i'm the rock so
i don't know what else to say i mean i
got we got tom cruise in the house
hey everybody i'm tom cruise yeah nico's
tom cruise
ren have you won a title yet
silence awesome okay real quick i almost
won
the indiana jones one but why was it
indiana jones and not harrison ford
because indiana jones is who we'd all
like harrison ford defeat
it just that literally just occurred to
me that like we have all these actual
celebrities and then a fictional
character played by a celebrity
you know i don't i don't know i don't
know i don't think we think about it
that hard
it's more just like hey this could be
fun it's a tower of cards man and you're
just going to knock it all down
you know he's unveiled our uh
the flaw in our content strategy
youtube's going to shut down the channel
now that they know
yeah oh no hey we got a big announcement
don't we
yeah so um guys uh
i don't know if you've been following i
don't know i'm just gonna say i don't
know before everything
no you may not be following what's going
on on corridor digital.com but if you
are
and you're a website member we've got
exciting news
crew cuts has been greenlit
that's right that's right the vlogs are
b-a-c-k they are back yes
um so what happened was we said hey
uh we've got a whole slate of shows that
we could possibly make
we put crew cuts out there and we said
you know what we'd like to make this one
here's a here's a low point goal
let's get it going and it hasn't even
been a week
since we've announced the green light
feature and today
today the uh crew cuts show
has been funded so yes by the time this
podcast comes out
there may be already the first episode
so if you guys are interested
we're going for it on corridor
digital.com
there's a new show
this is cool man looking at these other
shows too it's like
functional filmmaking's got a chunk
taken out of it already son of a
dungeon's got chunk taken out of it
already
yeah tactical reloads though that one's
gonna take a while that's an ambitious
show
yeah it's gonna take a while but when it
when it happens it'll be worth every
penny
yeah no functional filmmaking is
slightly ahead of son of a dungeon in
terms of
percentage towards uh towards completion
and um that's gonna be another fun one
to make
i mean yeah yeah this is great the
website's looking so slick these days
the background is the motion tracking
triangles you like that
you like that that is yeah we added that
in
just a little you know a little visual
distinction
i might finally have a new home page
instead of the default like mozilla
firefox home page
you're using firefox niko yeah i got
tired of how much memory chrome is
taking up these days and you know
google you know i gotta say that not for
being a giant mega corporation they
it could be a lot worse but uh you know
kind of like not selling my data
all the time okay so
then again it's like you can google my
name and there's like
you know i'm on the internet people know
who i am no see nico
we don't know who i am let me give you
the zuckerberg response
uh facebook doesn't actually sell your
data uh what we do
is we we take all of the data and then
we
we tell you what the data is but we
don't actually
sell it to you we still own it you just
you just buy access to it and then we
tell you what it is
right we give you a summary of the data
yeah so it's not selling your
information
right right right
okay mark thanks thanks for that
thank you marky mark
thanks mark wahlberg yeah you know
so it's really cool the crew cuts has
been greenlit and
it's super exciting to have like a show
that's for corridor digital.com for all
the people that
wanted to see the vlogs back and wanted
to support us and make it happen
in a site where we can do it without
having to worry about the algorithm
we can now support it on
quarterdigital.com and if you're
listening to this and you're not a
member consider going over there and
subscribing
within a week yeah i can't i thought it
would take at least a week
maybe it's a little scary how fast it
happened it is because
you know this is very intimidating like
once we put these shows out there as
soon as they get made
then we have to make them we gotta we
gotta yeah we got work to do boys
yeah now but we got daniel's doing an
amazing job so far with putting the
stuff together
yeah yeah no um so espec another special
announcement on the
crew channel will happen on friday this
week
um yes so stay tuned for that
uh but i want to kick things off for the
first topic of conversation here if you
don't mind jake go go go for it
all right let's do it ren wren why did
you cut your hair
it was that's not it it was providing
too much drag
wait drag why are you you were trying to
go fast recently
that's such a bad intro
[Laughter]
there was one event recently
so everybody probably already knows this
like listening to the podcast but you
know what who doesn't like a good hype
moment so here we go
all right wren is probably one of the
best one-wheelers i know
uh he is very fast faster than the
entire group
and recently future motion held a race
for the rail which is their
world championship one mil race and they
picked 10 people to go
and they left three slots open as wild
cards and for some reason they didn't
pick ren for the first ten people to go
and ren's like you know what
i can make a video and submit it and get
that wild card slot because it's a
popularity vote
and so uh you know ren does that and
uh you know all of us listening on this
podcast are fans of ren
um and so needless to say wren blows out
the competition with the vote
by like what was it 7 000 votes yeah i i
it was a little embarrassing
so ren gets picked for the empty slot
for the wild card slot
and here's the thing everybody's
doubting him right wren just got in
because he's got
a youtube following just because he's
popular i mean he actually hang with the
big boys
that is exactly why i got in
yeah he's just a dude rancher man so
ren's got a chip on his shoulder he's
got something to prove
and thus let's enter day one wren tell
us the story
of the rail okay well i mean yeah just
to kind of like add on to your little
backstory there it's like
i mean you're absolutely right so what
they they had they actually invited nine
people where originally it was just
seven people
then they added two additional women and
then they had three additional wild card
spots that they left up to the community
and i don't think they exactly
anticipated that i would want to join on
this
because i don't think anyone in the one
world community like took me seriously
including future motion themselves uh
they knew that i like
was this popular youtuber who made
youtube videos with the onewheel but
like
beyond that they didn't think i had any
skill they didn't think i had any speed
other than my friends here in la that i
ride with who uh i can keep up with you
know like brendan and jamie who
are the other two wild card members
brendan the guy who went on to win the
entire race i've ridden with for a
couple years now
a wild card won the entire race yeah
thanks
so i don't know how much you know about
any of this stuff no i don't i don't
i don't yeah i don't know the end of the
story in the end moving on
yeah yeah so though it was cool that uh
you know both my friends here in la were
able to join us on the wild card
so out of they narrowed down everyone
okay
everyone got to submit a little video it
had to show speed
skill and heart and i just made a silly
video of me trying to drink
tea out of a teacup going down a really
rough road uh on
like a trails like that that shows all
of those skills right you know
speed and skill while not spilling my
water in the end it kind of just looked
like a silly
goof but hey you know what i got in
so we all show up we all
had to first submit a negative covid
test
uh within a few days where did you go
you said you all showed up where did you
show up yes
so we went to utah this uh town just
outside of
huntsville utah so it's like an hour
north of salt lake
city we're all going to be competing on
this
this ski resort called snow basin and
man oh man the future motion team was
like super secretive about everything in
fact
so much so that they're like we're not
even gonna tell you the location
of the race until two days before you
show up and so two days before we show
up they tell us location is
powder mountain so
they're still being that's where we went
with sean oh is it really
okay yeah yeah yeah i mean yeah it was
cool we showed up there's this big lake
uh and then so it's thursday night
all the racers are there and they break
the news okay it's not actually powder
mountain it's going to be this place
called snow basin
oh which is closer and i think a little
smaller i'm not quite sure but basically
we had the run of the place
kind of there are a lot of mountain
bikers and hikers that we had to share
everything with but
whenever official races were going
everything was locked down pretty hard
uh yeah so we were not allowed to know
any of the
events so okay so to preface this last
year
this is the fifth year they've put on
race for the rail it's their annual
racing event in the last four years it's
always been this big thing last year was
the biggest one i don't know how many
people showed up i want to say between
like two and 300 racers
showed up and so the first two days
friday and saturday are all qualifying
rounds everyone's doing time trials and
then they narrow it down to the top 16
people
top 16 fastest times and they go on to
actually do the race for the rail
in these heats that's pretty competitive
it's very competitive yeah
and this year because of kovid they
didn't want to have a giant
you know convention type organization so
they invited the top
nine racers from last year with three
additional wild cards and so that's
that's where we're at there are 12
racers uh most of them
are like literally the top of the game
and i
am someone who likes to ride onewheels a
lot and i like to
go fast and i i i feel like i've gotten
pretty good at it
over the last like four and a half years
of writing but
i don't know how i stack up against
actual
racers and we're talking the best of the
best are here we got
the float life crew here you know jeff
raquel bodie
we have uh last year's winner the winner
from the year before that it's worth
mentioning that you've talked about
bodhi
many times and how he's probably the
best trickster on the one wheel
let alone writer yeah no and so that's
that's the other thing is that there's
this whole
separate like movement that has been
born out of one wheeling and that's just
doing tricks and it feels very much like
the early days of skateboarding like
back in the early 80s
when you know this guy would like do a
thing with his foot and the whole
skateboard came off the ground and
everyone's like
what did you just do and he's like i
don't know but i'm calling it an
ollie and then goes on to invent the
the kick flip uh i'm blanking on his
name again uh
hawk no not tony hawk
no he did a ted talk i can't think of
his name uh
it doesn't matter albert einstein yes
albert einstein created the kick flip
and so yeah that's kind of where we're
at with one wheeling but the problem is
that like
it's these a lot of these tricks can
break your board oh rodney mullen
ronnie mullen thank you thank you thank
you you did did you
know you didn't yeah i did he's in tony
hawk
he's in tony hawk's pro skater i heard
you say bob bernquist
i heard you say einstein so okay so
yes bodhi is a very good trickster so is
so is jeff jeff mccosker from the float
life and so
is kyle from wheel fun stuff who was
another wild card
entry who didn't win the popularity
contest he's based out of san diego
these guys are like literally creating
new tricks like they're doing heel flips
and kick flips and
all kinds of weird turns and pop shuvits
and stuff with the onewheel
stuff that like literally no one thought
was even possible just like two years
ago
let alone one year ago so yeah but
we're in a race we're doing like
freaking
downhill hardcore racing and there are
four
races going into this whole thing the
first one
okay before we get all to that we had we
got divided in teams so they uh
of the four women of the group uh two of
them ended up getting chosen to do kind
of like the whole middle school round
robin
uh you know i pick you i pick you and
then it goes down and then it's
literally just me and my friend jamie
are the last two people to get picked
i'm just like this is my middle school
experience all over again
and at this point i'm wanting to embrace
that i'm like please make me the last
person selected
i want to be i want to claim the
official underdog
spot and even that was taken from me i
was selected second to last
so yeah my friend jamie was picked was
picked last um
and so is the two teams so that was
thursday night so then friday
we go into this and it's uh there's two
race events of the day and the first one
we all take the gondola all the way up
to the top of the ski mountain we are
required to have 50
battery so that tells me we're gonna
race down to the bottom of the mountain
but the race itself is a team race and a
switch
team can get their entire roster across
the finish line the fastest
and basically what that means is that
it's the slowest writer
from each team is racing each other is
kind of what that came down to
so we decided to try to be as a group
and just like
i ended up being in the lead for most of
it just scouting lines being like you
know stick to the left you know this
this turns a little wishy-washy stick to
the right over here
and but we're all kind of going as a
cohesive group
uh the other team they're just like full
send everyone just get to the bottom as
fast as you can and then they ended up
beating our time by like three minutes
it was kind of ridiculous yeah um yeah
so i was like okay well
okay uh so then the second race of the
day was a few hours later and at this
point i
i had taken some really hard tumbles
going down the mountain
and they're on camera somewhere future
motion hasn't released that footage yet
but
i took a couple practically what do you
mean
no they were raising hard tumbles that
was all part of the race that was the
actual race and so that was the thing
we were dropping 4 000 feet over the
course of around three and a half four
miles
and the first like chunk like the first
quarter mile to half mile was easily the
sketchiest terrain i'd ever gone on like
nico
we've ridden some pretty hard stuff
before none of that compares to what we
did for race of the rail
like none of it and and so this first
bit is basically just going down a giant
gravel field at a
really stupidly steep incline we're
talking rocks anywhere the size of like
gopros to full on like watermelons
so you're tail scraping potentially the
whole time if you're trying to slow down
yes yeah and on top of that
we're the first group to go so we don't
know that we should not
go that fast through this one section so
we're all bombing it
and everyone eventually kind of bails
off the board at one point and
i get down to the and i bailed it once
or twice going down this get back on you
keep going then down at the bottom of it
i hit my board hit a rock
and went this way and i went that way
and i just tumble and i hit my
my hips so hard so hard fortunately i
was wearing that motorcycle jacket that
my friend lance hashida let me borrow
and that like literally saved my life on
the second day i hit my back really hard
i'm fairly confident i would have broken
my back without that
back plate like i'll get i'll get to
that story you're really hard man
dude i was like that first bit i was
going so hard i was like okay
i have to kind of take it easy and then
i was able to catch up with the rest of
the group past them and then but we just
stayed as a group the whole time
and this was where it kind of confused
me a bit because i'm now in the lead
easily i'm i'm like trying to go faster
but at a certain point i literally
stopped and turned around i was like
where is everyone i had to wait for them
to catch up and so
you know ori and dave tahoe dave were
two racers that are very fast
and dave won it two years ago and he was
second place last year
so he's also a very fast guy one of the
most humble people i've ever met
and you know they're they're behind me
but it's because they're sticking with
uh the rest of the group and
i was like okay all right i didn't get a
good
uh gauge on how i stacked up against the
other fast racers
from this first event so that's where
the second event came in but
problem is that it was like six thousand
feet
base altitude up there and i started
getting cramps in my legs
and from the lack of oxygen and i i was
like i hate a banana
what's wrong i thought i was on top of
my nutrition i thought i was in shape
and then
that second race came in and just kicked
my butt because it was
oh my god that second track was so
difficult it was so gnarly because
you go up and then you're doing like
these mountain bike trails
where there are certain sections of just
nothing but rock where it feels like
you're riding over a lava field
and there are sections where it's like
you have to hit this rock with enough
speed
that you could bonk over it and catch
enough air to clear the next two rocks
after it
and then land and keep going otherwise
you're getting off your board
and this is expected of every racer just
to be able to bonk over that stuff
and catch air and then keep going and
then going around stuff and
and i was doing really well the first
half of that second race and i was like
all right i might i have i've yet to
even fall off i think i might actually
do really good
and then the second half of the race my
legs started cramping up i started
losing strength in my thighs
to the point that like i would i would
land after hitting a jump
and my leg didn't have the strength to
like withstand it
and oh man i i fell off several times my
board fell off the trail at one point
tumbling down i was like no fortunately
i got caught up in some bushes so it
didn't take too much time
there there was a lot of confusion about
directions on this race like there were
forks that weren't clearly labeled and
at one point i i
probably wasted 30 seconds not being
sure where to go because there's this
fork to the right i was like
okay i think this is the way to go this
is the way i remember going and then
just at that moment i saw a racer going
up the hill
the guy after me and i was like oh yeah
this is the way back and i i get
oriented to go that way and then i hear
nope oh
right rant run
which way did you have to go watch where
did we go we never know now did it go
left or right
you saw the guy going up the hill but
oh no does that mean that the guy was
going the right way or does that mean
that the guy tricked him
i don't know he wasn't supposed to go
that way all right jake let's take bets
did ren blue scream
or did his internet cut out uh his
internet cut out
he thinks i think he blue screen well i
think he's
yeah i think he blue screen maybe it
means he lost his recording too
christian cut cut to his oh man before
we go any further
it's time to tell you guys about today's
sponsor story blocks now
yeah if you listen to this podcast
you've probably heard me talk about
storyblocks in the past
and there's actually a very specific
reason for that now they like to sponsor
this podcast because we actually use
storyblocks here at corridor digital
whether you're just an amateur creator
or an aspiring professional or already a
professional creator yourself
we've all come across the moment you're
working on a project you're trying to
finish it
and you're thinking look you know would
be perfect here i just had b-roll
of this thing or if i just had a sound
asset that that sounded like this or if
nobody would save me a few hours here
a motion graphic or some sort of after
effects template that i could just drop
into this title sequence and it would
make my life so much easier and i'd get
this project done
way faster we've all experienced that
and storyblocks
is the solution for us here at corridor
digital why because with an
unlimited all-access plan we can
download as much
from the site as we want in high quality
4k
a site that's constantly being updated
and we can use that
wherever we want so whether or not we're
working on a project for a client or
we're just working on a project for
youtube
or we're just working on a project for
ourselves storyblocks
has the solution when it comes to all of
your stock asset needs
i don't need to tell you how nice it is
to have a place where you can go
where every time you get to that moment
in a project you just go storyblocks so
if you guys are interested in making
your life easier
or you want to just add another tool to
the arsenal of things
that you have as a video creator head on
over to storybox.com
corridor cast or click the link in the
description below
okay okay storyblocks.com corridor cast
you're good you're not gonna forget
okay back to the podcast he's gone
oh no oh no
quick fill in the gaps oh he's back
maybe doing blue screen red
god dang internet cut out the internet
cut out for a moment
jake was right
i was literally about to text you i was
about to try to like tether into my
phone
[Laughter]
we don't know what happened we you you
were in the middle of the left you wait
you were in the middle of the story and
you're like and then i sat there for 30
seconds and i was looking both ways and
then i saw another racer
up on the other end of the hill and that
made me want to go
[Laughter]
dang i kept talking for a bit after that
too so which way did you go
so i was about to head up that road
because i'm like because it
curls back and then it comes down to the
starting line and that's you know where
the guy was going bode was the guy after
me
and i was like okay that's the way to go
and so i get oriented to go that way
and then i hear it off in the distance
straight go straight
and i'm like okay dang it because i had
already gotten off my board turned
around
and gotten back on it and then i had to
get off again turn it back around
because there's not enough
room to like literally turn around uh
and i didn't have the strength to do my
little 180.
but yeah and so i get down to the bottom
and i didn't uh i placed ninth place
i don't know how much of this i'm
retelling again no this is brand new
okay so
i think my final time was like nine
minutes and 52 seconds and the guys that
i wanted to be competitive against were
getting like
seven and a half minutes to nine minutes
oh
no uh so dom and body both placed very
good times i think
dom's time was like seven and a half
minutes or something like that
so you you this is the individual race
so okay this is the second of four races
and they're individual time trials okay
but in order to win the entire event
your team collectively has to have the
shortest time
does that make sense yeah yeah that was
the other thing they had this whole like
money purse thing that each team
if you win that event had three thousand
dollars going to your team
and there are three events so you could
potentially end up getting
nine thousand dollars but you can only
take
home that money nine thousand split
between
the six racers but you can only take
home that money if a racer on your team
won the final race for the rail
oh that's a catch it's a bit of a catch
so let's say hypothetically we won all
three events
but then brendan who was on the other
team went on to win the whole thing
we got nothing that's lame
it would have been lame but it didn't
play out that way so how did
how did they determine who the best
individual
is i think that's coming the shortest
time
what do you mean okay yeah right so so
but it wasn't just a team
thing like so yes so it was it was team
it was a team thing in the sense that
like someone's got to win this event
uh one of the teams do but the actual
qualifying times were what
those times were used as qualifying
times for the final race for the rail
and how we ended up getting bracketed in
the heat
for the final race they're going to be
three heats of four people each
so in this in this uh race number two of
four races
you placed ninth yes not last place
it wasn't last place which to be honest
was the one thing that i actually wanted
or at least that was the thing i said
out loud that i wanted
in reality i wanted to do first yeah i
just didn't want to be last i didn't
want to i want because it's like
going into this whole thing no one knows
anything about who i am other than like
i
i have like this personality online
right and i wanted to prove to them that
i deserve to be here i wanted to prove
to all the other racers that submitted
wildcard submissions
that you know their them getting snubbed
wasn't in vain
well yeah there's two onewheels in your
back in the back under your video feed
by the way
you oh yeah you lost this is where they
live
you lost that race by a minute and a
half though ren
yeah so i mean there were the gap that's
okay there were two
racers that were a lot closer um i think
raquel had a closer time and zou
had a had a closer time they were around
like nine minutes and six seconds and
nine minutes and 15 seconds
oh but yeah it was a big gap and that
was why that whole night i was kind of
depressed being like dang
i don't deserve to be here did you have
like us
did nick capture you having like a
self-reflective moment in the mirror
like in the in the hotel room like kind
of
yeah i guess we also haven't clarified
we brought nick along with us
and recorded an entire uh thing you know
yeah a whole you know he was there
documenting the entire process all the
highs and lows that i went through all
the highs and lows
all the other racers went through it's a
big thing lots of footage it's going to
be another couple weeks before that
video comes out uh but i think it'll be
a really good one
yeah in the end an underdog story had a
big through line through the whole thing
so i think it'll be a good video
uh because brennan we you know he went
on to win the whole thing and
you know he's a friend of mine we're
gonna have him come by the studio
probably next week
to show off his uh trophy his nunchucks
his golden nunchucks
so i totally lost where i was in the
story uh so you just finished race two
of
four yes yeah and you got ninth place
and i was and i was bummed about that
and so
then the next day uh we show up and
there's like some media time there's a
professional photographer on on site
taking photos of us going through these
trails and i'm just kind of like
hanging out having a good time but the
third event is scheduled for early that
afternoon and i'm kind of just like all
right this is my last chance to prove
myself
and so we get up there and it's a relay
race this is up at the top of the
gondola we're at like 10 000 feet
altitude up here
and it's a small like maybe a half mile
loop
very technical train but not as
technical as the second race track
it was so it's much shorter we uh this
guy named tucker das
uh came and flew his drone around and
got some fpv footage of us so you can
actually clearly see like how cool of a
track this was niko you'd love to race
this one
but uh sounds great yeah no there were
great moments of like you're going along
and it's like
smooth uh slightly rocky single track
but then there'd be bits of like big
rocks that you'd have to navigate
through but there was always a line that
you can actually ride through if you're
careful
as opposed to the second track which was
like hit it and hope for the best
so the other team went first and it was
a relay race it was just one after
another and everyone's averaging
somewhere between two minutes 15 seconds
and like two and a half minutes
per racer and then our team goes up and
they they did really well they got like
i want to say like 13 minutes or
something like that total
uh so then we go up we get our orders
straight and i'm like the fourth racer
to go
and all right and i'm like i'm in the
zone at this point i am focused and i am
i'm coming at this like i'm going to do
this and i didn't want to like do a full
send where i could risk actually falling
so i don't know if i was giving it 90
maybe between 80 and 90 but i was
focused on just being careful to not
fall off the board
and to go as fast as i can through all
the straight bits
so i did it i managed to not fall off my
board and i was feeling good even the
final bit there were the hardest bit of
that whole race was like the final like
100 feet
where that's where it got like really
rocky really and i managed to get that
and finish over the finish line
and then i got my time back and i got
two minutes and 10 seconds
which is that was it put me in fourth
place
amongst everyone that's awesome
that's good and so i ended up beating
uh the only two people out of everyone
who raced the only
there were three people who beat me it
was dom who won last year
bodhi who is a very good fast rider who
is the kind of the favorite to win this
year is a big rivalry between dom and
bode
and dave tahoe dave who's joe
who's this 43 year old unassuming guy
who happens to be
stupidly fast out of one wheel he's been
on the podium like three years in a row
and he won it one of those years
second place last year yeah um
anyway they were the only and dave's
time was like two minutes and six
seconds so he only beat me by four
seconds
um was two minutes even bodie was a
minute 55. so i'm like pretty close
but i beat brennan's time i beat ori's
time uh
you know jeff mccosker's time i beat
those guys as times on this
track and of course they're going to say
oh i wasn't trying that hard i'm waiting
sure they were rodney mullins time
bob burn quests time yes
anyway tony hawk's time but here's the
thing though that made it so that like
i actually deserve to be here now i set
a time
that was amongst like the top racers
yeah that's huge i did it i did it that
was all i wanted i had no
i i didn't think i was going to win
anything i was hoping to just not get
last but internally i was really hoping
to
to earn the other racers respect that
was kind of the one thing
i wanted to earn their respect as a
racer not as a person i'm sure
i had no doubt i was gonna be able to
earn the respect as a person
[Laughter]
that's what i do i respect you as a
racer but i don't respect you as a
person
can i reject to the story for just a
second do it
so so this is the point i don't know if
every listing knows it's not but i've
been in the wilderness for the past like
eight days uh like literally in the
middle of
nowhere on the border between canada and
minnesota where there's it's just pure
wilderness like 20 miles in
uh that you had to get there without any
motors you had to do it through canoes
and hiking
so on the like on the way in this is as
far as we've gotten
in the story at least what i've seen
because i went in on
uh sunday morning and this is saturday
when you finish this race run
yeah and then for a week straight i
didn't have any cell phone coverage or
anything like that
and there's three things i was looking
forward to when i got back out
first one was seeing my wife my kid
again the second one was playing
microsoft flight simulator which i've
been looking forward to for like a year
and came out in the middle of the trip
and the third thing and one of like the
first things i did when i got out there
was i watched the race the finals wow
because i knew going in you had gotten
fourth place and the time's like oh
ren's competitive
i wonder what's gonna happen all right
tell us about the final race
so the final race this is the final day
and going into this race i was nervous
because like they they i don't know the
name of the team they hired to do the
whole live stream production but it was
a legitimate team
of like a dozen people they they
normally do i'm gonna get this wrong but
i think they do like the world surfing
championships
they're the ones who like broadcast that
on tv and stuff so this is like a legit
team
they are professionals who we worked for
them back in like 2009.
what yeah sam and i did the uh 2010 we
did the
surfers choice awards which is a live
stream show for all the titles
i think it was probably those guys dang
okay well yeah i mean they they had a
whole set up they had
you know multiple cameras multiple
wireless cameras as well on gopros on
drones and they they had a whole like
uh switching team just monitoring the
feed switching back and forth so it was
like it was
it felt like a real like full-on
production yeah you know big props to
the future motion team for making that
happen
uh but yeah so it's like we get up there
this is a thing so
i'm in the first heat i am the first one
to go down the mountain
with three other racers and i am up
against angel who was a teammate of mine
but she had been
uh kind of in the in at the back of the
of all of the times plus she also really
hurt her hip on that first race so i
think that was kind of slowing her down
quite a bit
so needless to say i wasn't too worried
about beating her but the two other
people i was racing against
were dom and brendan
[Laughter]
last year's champion and this year's
champion
so i was like okay but i didn't know
brendan was gonna go on and win the
whole thing
to be honest i don't think any of the
racers expected that it was kind of an
upset
everyone was expecting it to be either
dom or bodhi and so i knew i wasn't
gonna be able to beat dom
my only goal was to beat brendan so that
i can proceed to the next
heat and so i'm like all right brandon's
gonna sorry dom is gonna win this
brennan will be close behind and
hopefully i'm like right there giving
brendan a run for his money
and we get going down and i'm going fast
uh i'm behind i'm right behind dom i'm
neck and neck with brendan
and we're kind of going along brennan
gets ahead of me and then i hit like
i got stuck in this chunky bit in the
middle of the track
where it's just boulders essentially
half buried boulders and it was like
basically going down a staircase like
except i'm going 23 miles an hour you
know and so i was like
and so my feet just slowly vibrated off
the board and then i had to just
jump off and the moment the moment i
stepped off the board i knew it was over
i knew there was
absolutely no way i was going to catch
up and i was i was right and so
i spent the rest of that race just like
trying not to fall off my board just
having a good time with it every time i
went by a camera i was like
like yeah like putting my hands out
doing a wing motion and stuff like that
and then i get down to this point i'm
like coming up to this camera man i'm
like yeah i'm gonna make a face for him
and he's looking the other way hey
i'm coming by you should have your
camera on me and i didn't realize this
until after the race ended but
this is a totally normal thing in races
no one cares about whoever's not in
first or second place so the moment i
stepped off that board
i did not appear on camera for the rest
of the race
until after i had finished i'm not even
on camera finishing the race i'm on
camera going
you won you won what yeah i noticed that
when they got to the finish line when
they cut to the feed
they actually cut to the feed at the top
of the mountain instead of the bottom of
the mountain before they crossed the
finish line
yeah yeah that's classic
and racist though like uh for sure like
yeah having having to run enough track
to
to uh experience that
you know like you're like i was i was in
fourth this whole race
i wasn't on camera one time
yeah no it's like i totally get it i
totally get it but what i didn't know at
the time was that
the upset was occurring in my race
brennan passed dom
and dom was not able to recover and
brendan won that heat
i didn't realize that until after i
finished and everyone's like yeah
brandon i'm like wait
brendan won oh my god yes and yes
did did they determine the final winner
by two two heats or did they have the
did he make it on to like a final heat
then and racing so that's the thing
they're uh first round there are three
heats
and the top two races from each of those
heats go on to the second round
okay and the second round contains two
heats with three racers each
oh okay so they didn't race everyone
with the fastest times together in a
finale
like they just picked from those final
three heats
the fastest time
i i'm not exactly sure i mean the two
fastest racers from each heat
got bracketed out uh in this second
round so this is like a tournament
bracket where so yeah
it's a tournament dom and brandon
brendan brandon brendan
brendan brendan dom and brandon floaty
mcfly yes
to the next one and then from the other
heat two guys went on from that and
there's those four people racing against
each other
three and three three okay two heats
three racers each
yeah yeah and and that was so that was
when uh
oh my friend jamie won his heat he got
to go on uh which was another
uh unexpected thing for everyone because
he's a bit of a heavier guy
but here's the thing when you put him on
a downhill slope he is faster than
everyone and that's right sure enough he
beat everyone in that first race and so
that was also a bit of an upset because
he was racing against bodie and dave and
he beat okay
so red the question everyone is
wondering
what did you place i don't know my final
placement
what was your comparatively with your
final time
i don't know yeah they didn't do your
final time they're like he's not at
first he doesn't get a time either
like a lot of us are still waiting on
our times for that like i don't know
what my actual final time
for that for that race is i'd like to
know because i know brendan's final
final race was two minutes and 56
seconds
and that was the fastest run of the
entire day i wouldn't be surprised if my
time was like
three minutes and in like 45 seconds or
something i don't know
so hopefully less than that he'd only
beat you're
everybody dom in your heat he then beat
everybody again
in the next season afterwards exactly so
in the second round he was up against
dom and i think bodhi i think it was
those three guys
in that in that race and and same thing
happened again he was able to overtake
overtake dom man up against scottie
pippen and michael jordan
and yeah yeah and and he just
but he had good strategy going into that
race he had uh he knew the
the parts where he's able to go fast and
overtake and
and and even like the arc there's this
one challenging that was going through
the grass
where there was technically a trail but
it was like this wide
and it didn't give you any room to like
maneuver or anything so a lot of racers
kind of went in the grass but that was a
bit of a
a toss-up because there you know the
grass is bumpy and holy and
and several racers went down in the
grass but he managed to find the spot
where he was able to basically take a
really wide turn and then
come in uh with a really tight turn at
the end of that to overtake dom
on the the final section of sidewalk
that sounds cool
yeah it was it was honestly a really
exciting race we got kicked out of the
building at one point because me and a
few of the other racers who are out
were uh we were
hanging out in the building that the
live stream team was working in and
we're erupting like
oh my god because we're watching on our
phones just streaming the race like
everyone else
uh like oh my god and we got kicked out
because we were distracting the actual
live stream team
so ren if we had to average
all the times you place you got fourth
and one you got ninth in another
your seventh
best i i don't even want to give a
number for that because i think it's
it's it's
meaningful to put a number on it i feel
like we owe
a number one i think i ranked it about
number one
yeah i'd say that's where my my guess
would be how i ranked up against
everyone yeah
oh christian says uh you're the sixth
seed
that's the christian says this could be
from uh he sent through something six
seed he's looking at the tournament
brackets you said you're the sixth c
well the seed doesn't mean necessarily
that's how you finished though
oh it has your times here right okay 9
22 is what your time is oh that okay no
that was that was from that second race
gotcha those are all times from our
second race and so i wasn't the number
six
seed that was my number my number on my
jersey is number six
oh okay man so br brandon
so you heard it here first ren wykman
the sixth best
one wheeler
man it's crazy that brendan took uh
three heats in a row
dave is 43 years old and he took he was
in the final heat
mm-hmm it's nuts he's been damn tahoe
he's been on the yeah that's what i'm
saying he's like stupidly fast
he uh and he's so with doc boards
that was yeah so that was the other
thing we were we were told you had to
use stock boards
which meant zero modifications to the
tire the foot pads the bumpers the
battery nothing everything had to be
factory delivered it doesn't didn't have
to be new
you were we were able to use our own
boards as long as there are no
modifications so i actually borrowed a
friend's board
that was purely unmodified but it'd been
broken in it had like five or six
hundred miles on it
so i was going to use that and basically
right at the time we're getting there
they changed their mind like no everyone
has to use a board that is fresh out of
the box
and not a single racer was happy about
that because the vega tire which is the
stock tire that comes with the one wheel
is notoriously hard to ride
for for like trail riding it's it's it's
put in the one wheel because it's very
flat profile
and so it's a very stable riding tire
but
if you're wanting to do any sort of
carving it's got a lot of like turn
resistance and whatnot and so what all
of us did the night before
which we were allowed to do we were
allowed to break in
the tire however we wanted so i learned
some new things about breaking in tires
you shave down the corner of the tire by
basically grabbing the front
uh like this like you're holding like a
like a hard drive or something like this
you know you grab it here you activate
the front sensors
and then you tilt it back so the the
wheel is trying to like ride away from
you
and then you basically just tilt it on
its side and let it burn out on the
corner of the tire
and you just do that and you're hearing
like this
it literally sounds like someone's
burning out yeah in a car
and you know you're getting those
familiar fumes of burnt rubber you're
leaving behind a little stain on the
on the concrete and you just kind of do
that back and forth until you get a
little bit more of a rounded profile
the second thing you got to do is you
got to lower your psi down to around
like 5 psi
or less and you just you just ride
around for like a couple miles just
doing
really tight hard curves uh and
that'll break down the sidewalls of the
tire because the sidewalls are really
stiff on a brand new tire
and you can actually feel it it kind of
feels almost like it's like it vibrates
a little bit it's crunchy feeling
yeah and and that's just the the
sidewall is actually buckling whenever
it's going underneath you but the more
times it buckles the more broken in it
gets
and eventually that that crunchiness
starts going away and then you inflate
it back up and all of a sudden you've
got like this tire that feels great
and after like like two miles on this
tire and it's a broken entire and
it's like this is info i was getting
from you know jeff mccosker bodie dom
these guys are like oh yeah no this is
what you do and they're all doing it as
if it was like common knowledge i'm like
wow i'm learning so much
[Laughter]
that's really cool so as was the prize
ever
another onewheel um
no i guess it makes sense it's like
hi all you professional one-wheelers
here i have a one wheel it's like what
am i gonna do with this
well okay so there's a big asterisk to
that so all the writers were hoping that
we were gonna be able to keep the stock
board but
they their their budget was tight enough
that they didn't have it in their budget
to be able to give those boards away
they were already spending so much money
on everything else on all our travel and
all accommodations the kovid
restrictions were keeping
stuff complicated the whole like you
know streaming team was expensive
renting out the mountain was expensive
i'm sure
so it was a bit of a bummer that none of
us got to like keep the boards that
would have been cool but
i i don't know i i i got pretty close
with
uh the team as a whole from future
motion and i've developed a lot of
sympathy
for for them because you know they're
just trying to do the best that they can
with what they're allowed to do
and i i i see a lot of hate that they
get online
and having like talked with them a bit
now i think it's a little
undeserved a little bit and so i have
some sympathy for him now that being
said
it would have been really cool to get
some one wheels out of this so what
ended up happening
so again going back to the whole team
aspect
team delirium which was the other team
were in the end a much faster team did
they name you guys after
riding profiles yes yeah so it's team
delirium and team skyline so team
skyline and delirium
are they're approximately the same sort
of aggressive profile riding mode
uh on both the xr and the pint
respectively
and yeah so the other team they just
ended up having way faster riders and
they crushed us by a lot in every event
so that whole team
got a 9 000 purse that they were going
to split amongst themselves if one of
their racers
won the entire race brendan was on that
team
he won the thing so they all got the
money and brennan ended up getting i
want to say like
five thousand dollars i think maybe is
more i don't exactly know
so if he's like yeah actually yeah
that's what it was he ended up winning 6
because the six of them split that nine
thousand dollars
and he got five thousand for winning in
the one and a half thousand
for winning the whole thing and so what
they ended up doing is they they made
this deal that they could either take
the check for 1500
or they can take the one wheel
and that's what i think all of them
ended up doing i think
because there's this whole thing with
like hardware version i i don't want to
dive too into the the technical weeds
here because
of of things i don't want i'm sure
they're all purists about like you have
this iteration from this year because
they use this type of
hardware profile well it's because
future motion is fighting back against
modding
and so they've the from hardware version
onwards the controller board and the
battery pack are paired
so you can't repair them anymore without
replacing both
and it's like if you're if you're if the
bms and your battery dies you can't just
swap it out with a new one you have to
also swap out your controller board
it's it's a really unfortunate thing but
it's their attempt to you know
fight back against the very reliability
of if some one of their boards
you know exposed you know
even if it's not their fault at all like
their brand recognition is on the line
with that so
they're yeah it sucks as a person who
very much so supports the right to
repair
it's the same sort of mentality that
tesla takes and it's
it's a bit of a bummer but i get it so
anyway some of the boards that they were
racing were 4209 boards which were
boards that you can fix and repair and
so they're like yes
these boards are valuable they traded
those out
i also had the opportunity to buy it i
think they gave they were giving us like
off uh the full price to be able to buy
it so i had the option of doing that but
i was like
i was i was prepared to buy it i was
going to but only if i won enough money
from this event to do it what
what happens if you win the race but
your team doesn't have the overall fast
or lowest time you would still win the
money for you
mm-hmm but your team you're going to win
the nine grand your team yeah
i see interesting so yeah if dave ended
up winning who was on
our team dave would have won five
thousand dollars and the other team
would have gotten nothing
good old tahoe dave they wouldn't have
gotten anything even though they would
have had a fastest overall
yeah even though they would have the
fastest overall time mm-hmm
if dave would have won one look i i
don't mean to
that's how they chose to do it and it
seems like i don't know what their
financial situation is okay i'm not here
to judge
but i do want to say this like for
bringing everybody out and for as many
one wheels as they probably sell and for
as expensive as they are i just feel
like
you know the 175 dollar coupon off
thing not really doing it for me
again i'm not trying to dog on them but
like where is that coming from
see that that i think that was a pretty
shared uh
feeling and i i certainly felt that way
until i started talking with the team
and kind of like learned a little bit
more about how
how uh strapped they are like apparently
it's actually really difficult for them
to get boards because we're like what
are they gonna do with these race boards
like they can't give them away and
they're like no we're gonna use them as
like
boards for us anytime we need to go
anywhere use them for marketing research
or whatever like it's really hard for
them to get
or like if they go in events they have
to bring some boards out stuff like that
they do that quite a bit
your dog is apparently hard for them to
get boards in general
and and yeah it's like it's strange like
i feel like the marketing team is kind
of detached from the rest of the company
and like they don't even know what what
like the next one wheel
is gonna be you know like um i'm sure
they might have an idea but like
there's a lot of like separation between
like the
r d team the engineers and and like the
marketing and
yeah i don't know i have nothing but
respect for the entire marketing team
and the engineering team but that being
said i'm just
come on
right well it's not it's not like it's
the team is making that decision
right so of course somebody higher up is
making that decision my personal theory
which is
perhaps completely based on nothing but
i have a feeling that their whole
the whole company is run by lawyers
i think i i think that they're they're
very much so
like and again i this is unsubstantiated
speculation
i think that a lot of their decisions
are based on how can we mitigate risk
several times over it's happening now
the
imagine the coupon sounds like it's run
by lawyers i'm not gonna lie
you know based on like how the company
started too it's like you know
basically some surfers want a way to
surf on the sidewalk you know so they
kind of
put together this device it definitely
feels like
you know they were also like and i also
can't wait to be the ceo of a large
company in
you know san jose california like they
don't strike me as
that's where they're coming from
necessarily yeah and i mean and i get
that that desire to be
you know really conservative and whatnot
fall off of motorcycles
they're advertising these guys doing the
most extreme stuff possible on their
board
and the speeds that like dom and brendan
were hitting they were hitting 26 miles
an hour of suspension
riding i think brendan hit 25.9 and dom
hit 26.2 that's nuts
don't go faster than you're willing to
crash at yeah
and that was that was brennan's
mentality through all that he's like i'm
just i'm just gonna go as fast as i
physically can if i crash
so be it that's my fate and that was why
i wore the armor because i knew
i was gonna have to adopt that mentality
and i knew that there was a very real
likelihood that in doing so i would go
down and injure myself really hard
yeah you definitely want to be wearing
armor when you're racing that yeah
in those in that terrain like no
question about it
because you will fall oh so going back
to earlier when i said i would have
broken my back
they're like moto gp riders and they
don't wear armor
so uh this is after the third race on
the second day and we're heading down
the mountain because we did the whole
race up at the top there so now we're
doing the same track we did
the first race of the first day
and so now i have a better idea going
into it and sure enough
i was able to do that whole really
sketchy first section without falling
off my board once
and i did all right and i was going
through and jeff and i jeff mccosker
runs the float life awesome dude really
into one wheels and how they work and
how to like get them to do tricks and
stuff like that
and he has arguably some like the best
accessories that
you can get for the one with float
plates stuff like that and
so he's also very renowned for being
fast he won
the race for float life fest last year
which is the other
one world racing event i hope to make it
out there someday it's just in
i think north carolina so it's a little
hard to get out there and
anyway so he is a bona fide speedster
and so him and i are racing going down
this track
and uh i'm sure he was kind of taking it
casually i wasn't going super hard but i
was i was still kind of trying to push
it
but at a certain point i got stuck in
the middle again hit some rocks
and my board went out and i managed to
get one step down but that step
spun me around in the air so now i'm
flying head first down the
the trail down this fire road but upside
down so like i'm
my face is at the sky and i just land on
these rocks like boulder-sized rocks and
i slid
probably like 10 or 15 feet before
coming to a stop
and like you know jarred you know neck
whiplash from my neck my head hard
i tore up my brand new jersey that i we
had just been gifted
for the final race the next day i put it
on shredded it
[Laughter]
but it's great now because now they're
like you know they're cool uh cool scars
but
i was able to bounce up from that like
it was nothing but i am
nearly 100 positive i would have cracked
uh one of those like little fins on your
vertebrate you know
i'm sure i would have broken one of
those on that crash because i hit hard
no you got to wear a gator when you're
doing that at least
yeah yeah because i had a full-on plate
like an actual strong plate going along
my entire spine
yeah a good thing you did shoulder pads
elbow pads yeah yeah
ren that whole race sounds like an
awesome experience and honestly like
you know the speaking from i guess you
know the corridor side of things like
the one real
guys have always been very elusive to
try to talk to like it's it's
releases yeah well it's also clear that
they're like a very young company and
like
you know some parts of the company have
expanded it a lot other parts of the
company are still kind of catching up
it's like you know
it's like here at corridor like we're
hiring our first it guys like
you know 12 years into running this
business now yeah you know it's like
something's laying behind here and there
and like
you know trying to talk to them and
figure things out has always been hard
because there's not really anybody to
talk
they're they're elusive owners kepler
and shorts llp
[Laughter]
those are the guys that started it or
something some yeah some elusive
no-name firm law firm somewhere
you made those names up yeah i'm just
making it yeah cause i
do think they did take in a big uh
ownership
thing at some point in the last two
years but kyle is the name of the guy
who actually invented the onewheel i've
always wanted to meet him
kyle if you happen to see this come back
if you're 53 minutes into this podcast
[Laughter]
you owe it to us to uh at least say hi
no i have he's apparently very uh
reclusive and and
and so dude he just wants to ride his
one wheel man
he wants to ride his special one wheel
that no one else has that
has replaceable batteries and a motor
that's twice as powerful and all those
other things
i don't think we'll ever see replaceable
batteries in a one way i agree i hope to
be wrong but i don't think it'll happen
no i 100 agree i don't think the uh the
mechanics are there for it
yeah so after after we're done with this
whole podcast niko i'll tell you all
about my new one wheel battery because i
don't want to talk about it here
but it's a thing it's a thing speaking
of onewheels exploding
[Laughter]
yeah no that's super cool man like yeah
basically yeah it was it was an
incredible time
and the thing that i knew was going to
be my favorite part didn't
uh disappoint me my favorite part was
just hanging out with all the other
racers
all the other people there it was just a
really really fun time
just getting to know everyone and and
talking
shop you know with one wheelers like dom
is a 15 year old kid
he's 16 now uh he's 15 last year when he
won it so he's just like a high school
kid
and he's going into his senior year now
and like you know they're doing these
classes over zoom
so instead of like actually paying
attention to class he's like
repairing one wheels and like selling
parts on the side and like
making this whole business for himself
hustling like crazy
and so him and i talked shopping
controllers that's the mysterious
that's the mysterious dumb i've heard of
this kid
yeah now that you mentioned him in that
context he's come up in conversation
before and i'm like who's this
he's like one of those characters in
like uh like a
like an ocean's 11 assembly montage
and they're going around to like
different people and he's the kid in
high school
that's that's what he sounds like yeah
he just happens to be incredibly good on
a onewheel he
his like sense of balance and speed
going over really difficult terrain is
is almost unmatched so wren here's the
big question
yeah are you going to be back as one of
the regular riders next hell yeah or are
they going to make a wild card
again okay so i think next year assuming
uh
covet is is like a little bit more of a
past thing
all of this is dependent on whether or
not covet is a thing right
um if if there's a widely accessible
vaccine i'm sure there'll be a lot of
like
certifications that you got to go
through in order to make sure that you
have it or whatever
but if it's more of a group thing i'm
gonna have to go through the same time
trials everyone else does
but i'm telling you what right now i am
preparing for that
now i am there's a few things that i
gotta work on
one strength in my legs so i'm gonna
start doing squats
i'm gonna start doing altitude training
i'm gonna i'm gonna make sure that going
into that race next year i am not
suffering from lack of strength in my
legs that was the thing that killed me
on that second race
are you gonna get an altitude tent you
can get an
l you can get one of those you know i i
mean i don't know i i don't know how
seriously i'll take the altitude aspect
of it but
um yeah i i'm g i'm gonna try to be more
in shape for next year because i'm
definitely coming back next year now
that i know that i have a chance
at like getting into the top 16 i'm
gonna actually try hard for it because
this year i was just kind of coasting in
on
my current athleticism which isn't that
high
i'm like very standard athleticism
you're the default loadout yeah yeah
it's like even in all categories i'm
free to play
yeah yeah i have one more kind of
self-centered question
uh if you're gonna take the rest of the
boardsman here how would we stack up
could any of us hang
no oh no i'm sorry nico
i'm sorry no way man none of you guys
would stand a chance
like i'm talking about first place i
don't think anyone could take first
place i'm talking about
not taking the last place i'm just not
gonna
wait i don't know there's no way you're
gonna get me to ride down a mountain at
25 miles an hour going
if i fall i fall like i'm just not i'm
not going to get there
you know i think you could probably beat
a couple of the racers
i'm not going to name nancy but i think
i think you could probably manage it
like you dean
clint uh i mean jake if you wanted to i
think
like lyft could probably do all right i
could see cliff doing all right
he's got like that weight well then
again you go faster when you're heavier
but man cliff just floats over those
little bumps if you're going downhill at
least
but yeah it's um i mean not all the
races were downhill you know some of
them were
partly uphill flat you know
like a little one-wheel jockey just
floating over
but yeah it was very eye-opening because
i was i
i was at the top of my game through this
trip and even i was just struggling to
be competitive that's awesome that's so
cool when you're in that situation
like it's always so it's cool it's
struggling and like it makes you grow as
a person when you're in those situations
yeah so i yeah ultimately i was just
i had a great time hanging out with
these racers and i was just personally
happy that i i
was able to actually finally know that i
stand a chance against the top one world
racers in the world
like that's super cool yeah i didn't i
didn't beat everyone and i didn't
be even the people i did beat on that
one track that was just one race you
know like
yeah you know they beat me on the other
race so who's to say that
i'm faster than them you know there's
there's a lot of things at play but i
think i was also still
very much so a noob when it comes to
race mentality that's an actual
thing yeah that makes sense and you know
cutting it's not all about like being on
your board too it's about your like
racing lines and your techniques are
when you
accelerate versus decelerate and all
that stuff yeah that's a whole other
discipline you probably have the same
exact speed with two different people
but
one person knows a racing line better
than the other i mean that sounds like
you know how brandon got a head of uh
you know dom there when he took that
curve the right way yeah but yeah
i think it's super cool that in our
little one wheeling club we have
a uh somebody who raced in the world
championship
and somebody who's on the top 10 for
mileage in the world
yeah yeah so yeah has like almost 12
000 miles on his one xr he's also got
like 3 000 miles on his v1 he's up there
with like
the most miles ridden of anyone in the
world
yeah it's pretty crazy that's a good
story man
yeah i like it this whole podcast ended
up kind of getting dedicated that we had
other things we're going to talk about
but
you heard it here first you heard it
here first guys ren wykman
uh can officially claim the title of
fastest
one-wheeler on the planet oh my god
it does there is a certain amount of
cool that i have been feeling of like
man
i'm kind of technically one of the
fastest one real writers in the world
now like am i a professional one world
racer now like can i say that
yes i don't think i can i don't think i
can technically claim
that officially until it's a full-on
everyone can officially enter and it's a
fair race
because this year's race was a bit more
of a marketing stunt than it was a fair
race
that's just the nature of it i'm gonna
take it like sure
but for me to really truly earn that
respect that i was craving
i have to go next year and get in so
yeah that's all right
cool let's do it we'll document the
whole thing you'll be able to catch it
on court or crew
and probably on the corridor cuts vlog
on quarterdigital.com ren
you'll have a sponsor next year we'll
put it right here on your little
jacket we'll even get you a jacket i'm
gonna i'm gonna work on getting some
sponsors there's three different
companies that are are doing sponsors
that i haven't just
pursued at all i'm pretty sure i can if
i tried to work towards it
you have one from us mountain dew and
xbox
and and
yeah there you go cool well everybody
thanks for listening to the podcast wren
thanks for telling the story that's
super cool
red will you use my onewheel next year
for the tricks competition sure aye come
on no
yeah all right well and uh yeah every
listening
kododigial.com go check it out the vlogs
are up and they're live you haven't
gotten a subscription yet please
consider doing so
it helps us create some really cool
stuff that's right we're not going to
just be doing youtube videos anymore
we're going to be doing
cool things like narratives and vlogs
and all the other things that are a
little hard to do in the youtube
ecosystem these days
thanks to your direct support on
corridor digital.com
right that's right all right cool well
uh dudes i can't wait to do a ride with
you guys because i also have been
in the woods for a week but without my
one wheel jake uh
place a sad song as we leave for the
week until the next one
are those same two chords no this is a
minor of the same chord niko
oh come on it's getting there
[Music]
red is the best one-wheeler in the world
god no don't say that everybody
else is a turd
he's the best the very best
you can slowly fade out here christian
friend's
the best sing it with me
in the world i'm i'm amongst the best
the fastest in the world i can hang with
the fastest in the world
if everybody else is a turn
turn slow turn
[Music]
a slow and turtle
that's what turtle means